hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm gonna
be checking out from Rocco Rocca this is
so distracting I have periscope going on
right now
I was periscoping live and then a
periscoping while I was periscoping was
getting people saying I should totally
just film a reaction while periscoping
and it's super distracting because I
just keep seeing these hearts pop up in
textbook anyway yeah I'm gonna check out
from Rocco Rocco one of my favorite
channels Ronald McDonald playground
slaughter
I am so enthused to see this they these
guys dark violent comedy I [__] love
it it cracks me the [__] up so I'm here
today to check it out because this
channel is beginning a lot of requests
to do more short films and sketches and
I thought you know what I should be
watching more short films and sketches
before we really go gung-ho with it
because we're planning on doing that
very very soon guys
it's shame
sorry
No
Oh
now
oh right
got into in another to do it don't do it
Oh
yeah
some dart huh [__] man [__] racket
rageh Oh God what to say about that
Jesus Christ it's funny looking funny
that's as for damn sure it's a funny a
sketch I love just how sinister how dark
they're willing to go because it's like
the context of it is what makes it so
funny the fact that they're going so
ridiculously violent with a ridiculous
it's like what if Ronald McDonald went
on a playground slaughter they just
commit to it with the dark music the
violence what makes it really funny is
like he's doing this to kids and you
wouldn't expect such a violent sketch
about murdering a bunch of children so
dark it totally works it's so funny this
Ronald McDonald character is becoming a
classic man I like the plot to it of the
kid starting off with Ronald McDonald in
the mirror like it's Bloody Mary like
that out of all the righto McDonald
sketches I've seen so far this like
demonic version of him like coming to
life it's one of the funnier ones I like
it more than the chicken store massacre
were raw McDonald just a total
psychopath
I like the demonic thing about him the
ghost stuff that shit's funny
Sebastian Sierra want things Sebastian
Sierra one is talking about how Ronald
is scary and that's what's cool about
Ronald McDonald this too is like it's
all about the context of what's making
it funny like the actual writing of it
they're making it serious and violent
and disturbing and scary and thrilling
but the context of it being Ronald
McDonald makes it so hilarious what do
you guys think is so far in my opinions
or they're sounding good sounds good
alright cool cool cool getting approval
from everyone on periscope thanks narco
cinema same very deep I'll go deep in
you narco cinema yeah this is where the
jump cuts going anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe to the real
rejects subscribe today
become a real reject see all these
youtubers have like become a magnesite
do you know become a recognized er I
forgot what Chris Stockman says you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
vine periscope and um I'm on periscope
right now so I'm gonna give a shout out
who wants a shout-out first name I see
that ask for a shout-out
all right next one name that appears I'm
doing it whoa
see God whoa T God dude look he's right
here on my periscope I just wanted to
say to you woe to God you're a beautiful
man I'm looking the camera for this and
then that way you think I'm looking at
you I'm gonna put this right here I
think you're a beautiful man and woe to
God I would love for you to show me your
little spiritual angelic penis I can't
think of a smarter word than that penis
is the only word I could come up with I
don't require much wit for my videos I'm
not going to show my [__]